yeah so this episode is about what the
heck people who are part of the forward
party should be keeping an eye on for
election day and ideally what they
should do number one Evan McMullen in
Utah call your friends in Utah number
two this ballot initiative in Nevada
Branch was Voting uh and approval voting
to a lesser extent are on the ballot in
different places but this Bell
initiative of Nevada is the only place
where it's Statewide yeah it's huge you
probably have friends in Nevada where
are Utah probably more likely in Nevada
in this case I just what happens in
Nevada we hope doesn't stay in Nevada
[Music]
happy Halloween everyone it is my thrill
to welcome to forward the CEO the Ford
party himself Matt shinners Welcome Matt
Andrew glad to be back on the show the
podcast what do we call it the show the
podcast the legend nice uh so in honor
of Halloween and if you're listening to
this you can't see me I am literally
head to toe forward party swag I've got
the cap I've got the T-shirt the hoodie
the socks yes we have socks uh so
on the street people have been stopping
me all day saying well they do that
anyway because I get recognized a lot
but they'd say Hey you must be Mr
forward party and I say yes I am it's a
good I I think everybody should go as Mr
Ford or Mrs Ford party or whatever
forward party for Halloween and uh buy
some merch on our website because that
supports our operations yeah so this
code is about what the heck people who
are part of the forward party should be
keeping an eye on for election day and
ideally what they should do because this
episode is taking place essentially one
week out from election day
um so I'm going to speak for myself for
a little bit I'm going to say the most
high impact race for the forward party
on Election Day is Evan mcmullen's
Senate race in Utah what do you think I
absolutely agreed um you know he's
running as an independent out there
really interesting strategic play that
brought various groups together he went
to the Democratic party out there and
said hey you all have never won in Utah
you're never going to win in Utah
um I'm willing to work with you to find
some common ground to promote you know
the values that y'all find important to
protect our democracy against Mike Lee
who's you know he's got text messages
going back and forth on January 6th and
then lying about it during debates so
just talked with them and said hey let's
form a coalition where you know you know
that you would rather have me in the
Senate than Mike Lee so instead of
running a candidate just support me
instead that gives you you know a voice
in Utah that gives you a voice in the
Senate so let's work together make this
happen and you know it's it looks like
it's happening yeah the the polls are
pretty close oh it's happening I was
just in Utah campaigning last week
and I'm going to say it here right now I
think Evan McMullen wins this race
because when I was talking to utahns
sometimes they would say hey like Andrew
Yang what are you doing here and I'd say
I'm campaigning for Evan McMullen and
Evan McMullen had a lot of name
recognition enthusiasm but you know who
had a lot of negative enthusiasm was
Mike Lee yeah they would say oh is he
running against Mike Lee then yeah like
like Mike Lee is uh really unpopular
like people just don't like that guy yes
so I think the average utahn and when
you talk about the polls right now it's
neck and neck but the polls also have
it's something like 12 undecided and
Mike Lee's approval rating is
consistently in the low 40s so do you
really think that people are going to
say hey I'm not sure what to do here I'm
gonna go with the guy I don't like or am
I going to go with the the guy who maybe
is a little bit new to me I think the
undecided's break to Evan and he wins so
Curtis here first Andrew Yang thinks
Evan McMullen wins the most unlikely
Innovative almost unprecedented Senate
race in the country yeah and I I think
it's really exciting too because it's so
easy to fall back on the we're voting
against Mike Lee but Evan's also an
awesome guy yeah I've spent plenty of
time in a room with him hearing him talk
about things he's really interested in
protecting our country uh how long was
he in the CIA 11 years CIA operative
Middle East yeah so he was you know
fighting for our Democratic Values
abroad now he's doing it back here just
really willing to get in a room talk
with people just very values driven down
to earth great great guy so it's not
just about voting against Mike Lee which
we should be voting against Mike Lee
he's not a good guy but it's also voting
for somebody who's just representing
kind of the the forward path of finding
coalitions finding common ground
representing good values so a couple
more things and if you haven't dug into
Evan mcmullen's race I did write a blog
post uh well you can look it up it's
like independent Senator Andrew Yang
um you talked about how the Democratic
party got out of the way that effort was
first not a slam dunk because uh I think
it was something like 700 votes for
getting out of the way up to 500 votes
for running someone which means if a
hundred Democratic State officials had
changed their minds then we wouldn't be
having this conversation all likelihood
and the key figure was Ben McAdams who's
a former Democratic member of Congress
in Utah the most popular Democrat in
Utah who has been campaigning for Evan
McMullen and he urged people in the
party to say look let's get out of the
way for Evan so here's some more math 39
of utahns voted for Joe Biden in the
presidential are they going to vote for
Mike Lee no so you'd think that there
were some Democrats who have been out of
shape about the fact that they weren't
running a candidate but now they've
gotten on board and are excited about
Evan so if let's say the 39 go to Evan
then the question is can he peel off 12
of the 58 who voted for Trump in the
last election and the key signal here is
that Mitt Romney who sits next to Mike
Lee in the U.S Senate said I'd like them
both I'm not going to endorse which by
the way when I was out campaigning in
Utah I literally ran into Romney's
um from there the you know the Romney
name uh that is he's a big family
always so uh there the fact that MIT uh
is essentially blessing Evan and saying
to moderate Republicans in Utah this guy
is all right uh has been enormously
helpful yeah yeah and you know if if
Evan ends up when Evan ends up what if I
mean you know it's like I'm I'm saying I
think he wins but right now most
prognosticators still have him as the
underdog yeah no absolutely but you know
one of the biggest narratives out there
for why uh new party won't work why
independent candidates won't work is
they're spoilers it'll never happen like
they're just out there and we're really
seeing in Evan that there are a lot of
really great Americans out there really
great Patriots out there who don't
identify with either the parties and if
we can get them into elections if we can
get them running on these new party
lines uh and they can win people start
to believe you know and that's one of
the biggest things that's stopping from
happening is everybody's so afraid of
throwing their vote away or whatever you
know BS excuse they want to use to say
like it could never have happen it's
about to happen and so let's talk about
what happens if Evan wins and hopefully
this is a spur for people listening to
this or watching this to say hey how can
I help
call someone in Utah uh volunteer for
Evan's campaign donate 5 10 20 bucks to
Evan's campaign so that they have all
the resources they need down the stretch
but let's say Evan wins he's going to
show up in the U.S Senate in January and
how many U.S senators does it take to
impact or even determine policy nowadays
I mean we saw in the the last couple of
years one one person one so people who
say hey this new Party Movement can't
succeed if you have a U.S senator who by
the way would become the most popular
guy in Washington if you wind up with a
50 50 splitter a 5149 split which uh I
think it's going to be one of those
scenarios and we'll talk about that next
week we make midterm predictions this
week is all about what the forward party
is getting behind for the midterms but
we could have an independent U.S senator
by by the way he might be joined by
another Senator or two who also are
breaking from their party they could be
the fulcrum in the U.S Senate as early
as January of 23. yeah and it's
interesting with the way that the Senate
Works everybody complains so much about
like some of the rules in the Senate
like you know filibuster and things like
that but those rules get set by the
members there's some constraints on
there but from day one you know Evan's
got power if it is that split say like
hey you know I'm going to support the
party that is willing to implement the
reforms that are actually going to let
us get some stuff done get committees
formed in order to you know talk about
these issues put stuff forward get rid
of some of these procedural steps that
prevents us from bringing things to the
floor actually force people to make
votes on things instead of just you know
secretly handing a piece of paper along
and saying I don't want to vote on that
thing and all of a sudden the bill is
shelled for a while you know there's
there's a lot of behind the scenes power
that would be wielded in that case uh
you know and from what I know about Evan
he's probably thinking through all those
things right now yeah this is one of the
complaints about Mike Lee by the way is
that he he's not someone who's trying to
get anything done uh and he'll make
really obnoxious votes just based on
upon being like what he calls principle
but most people would be like being a
jerk
so uh so it's one reason why his
reputation is very negative in Utah I
think Evan's going to be the opposite uh
Evan's going to be trying to build
coalitions and get things done across
party lines possibly which is how are
you doing which he's already doing and
we're seeing it with his campaign in
Utah okay so again Evan mcmullen.com the
most important Senate race from forwards
perspective
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
life doesn't come with a user manual you
know what I mean sometimes you have to
figure things out for yourself and
sometimes what you really need to figure
out is what's going on inside your mind
inside your brain therapists are people
who are trained to help us unpack our
thoughts our emotions how we are feeling
and make sense of it I first saw a
therapist when I was in my teenage years
and I've been a huge believer ever since
better help is the world's largest
therapy service it has matched three
million people with professionally
licensed embedded therapists available
100 online and it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it cannot be simpler no waiting
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapist learn more and
save 10 off your first month at Better
Health help.com slash Yang that's
betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash get some help today
[Music]
I would say the second biggest deal for
us is something that the national press
isn't going to home in on but it's
very very pivotal for us and our
movement is the ballot initiative in
Nevada with
nonpartisan primaries and ranked Choice
voting essentially implementing
something very very close to the Alaska
system in Nevada yeah and that's a
massive deal because the more places
that start to roll out these you know
the nonpartisan primaries the ranked
Choice voting or any alternative voting
system matter like if you want to
promote approval voting that's that's
another great one and that's got some
momentum in uh in Utah as well in some
other areas these are the things that
make it a lot easier for us as Americans
to hold our elected officials
accountable to vote for the people that
we want to vote for instead of trying to
come up with some weird strategic vote
where you know I'm voting for this party
even though I don't like them because I
like the other team either even worse so
getting this through in Nevada really
important
um just at a certain point that Domino's
are going to fall with the more
jurisdictions that are implementing
these reforms people get excited by it
like you know I just filled out I
dropped off my ballot uh my mail-in
ballot yesterday and New Jersey and
going through you know a lot of the time
I had no choice like either vote for
this person or not because there's only
one candidate but for some of the other
ones where you know there's a few
candidates and I don't like some of them
I like other ones I'd love to be able to
express that in some way through ranked
Choice voting through approval voting I
can't do that right now and the more
places that implement it the more
jealous I'm getting the more jealous the
the rest of the country is going to get
on
having the ability to do the same thing
and you know there's plenty of races uh
you know obviously I'm the CEO of the
Ford party I've been a supporter of new
parties for you know over a decade at
this point plenty of races where I would
have loved to have voted for somebody
but it was just too close and so I went
for the lesser of two evils I would love
the opportunity to be able to say like
no these are the two people who if
either of them made it through I'd be
happy and if that person made it through
I would not be happy so let me let me
let the government know that that's what
this country is supposed to be based on
yeah so the Alaska system got a ton of
press because Sarah Palin lost to Mary
peltola which probably would not have
happened under a conventional system
less prominently talked about was the
fact that Lisa murkowski got through her
primary which probably does not happen
in a conventional process where if you
looked at the House Republicans devoted
to impeach Trump eight out of ten of
them lost in the primary unheard of in
the sense that ordinarily your primary
is a bit of a cakewalk and then the two
that got through were in Washington
state where they had like a top two
jungle primary and so you needed a funky
system for someone to get through yeah
their primary if they voted to impeach
Trump Lisa murkowski voted to impeach
Trump and she got through because Alaska
had this system in place which was
non-partisan open primaries you can vote
for anyone of any party combined with
ranked Choice voting and if Nevada
passes it then it's going to seem like
it's gone from Alaska to Nevada and then
it'll be on the ballot in other states
in 2024 and you can liberate two four
six eight ten U.S senators from having
to worry about a Party primary which by
the way is what's making them so
irrational and crazy and uh I know for a
fact multiple U.S senators have gone up
to Lisa murkowski in the Senate and said
we Envy you so much that you don't deal
with the believe it or not like they
they feel captive to the system too so
if this passes in Nevada it would seem
like it's sweeping the country and if it
does not pass in Nevada then it's going
to be a massive missed opportunity I
want to actually give people the
backdrop over 16 million dollars is
being spent trying to help nevadans
understand this bound initiative the
Democrats have spent millions of dollars
already fighting it on legal grounds
because you know that it it makes things
less closed and uh predictable for them
so their rationale was it's too
confusing for voters which obviously is
garbage given that my nine-year-old and
seven-year-old can count to three and
Order what they want and
85 percent of alaskans found it easy to
use I think it was 88 percent of New
Yorkers so
uh so it's an unprincipled objection but
the Democrats are fighting it
um and I I will say that if it does not
pass in Nevada it's going to be a real
loss of momentum it's absolutely going
to be a massive loss of a momentum and
uh loss of momentum in a very positive
direction for the country murkowski made
it through her primary because of it but
you know we just saw it this week her
and peltola uh cross endorsed each other
across party lines for that and when
would you have ever seen that except for
an unbelievably extreme situations in
the past and imagine a world where
instead of just endorsing the member of
your party you're actually thinking
about the candidates and saying which
one of these people do I think would
result in better outcomes for the
American people for alaskans in this
case and you know that's that's
something that ranked Choice voting or
any of these other systems really
promotes is not just appealing to the
most extreme base but finding the the
common ground because you want to be
people's second choice you want to be
people's third choice what you don't
want to be is the person who you know
some people in the in the state don't
vote for and so murkowski isn't
appealing just to the you know the
extreme right she's appealing to
everybody which includes Democrats
moderates out there if we can bring that
to Nevada that would be huge as well if
we can bring that to the rest of the
country it would be massive because the
caliber of candidate we would get and
the disposition of the candidates we
would get would be radically different
would be people who actually are putting
the country first instead of worrying
about how to appeal to the most extreme
10 in their party yes and if you want to
help make this happen in Nevada you can
call nevadans and explain to them the
importance of this ballot initiative we
have call uh call Banks set up uh every
day between now and election day so
number one Evan McMullen in Utah call
your friends in Utah number two this
ballot initiative in Nevada
you probably have friends in Nevada
where Utah probably more likely in
Nevada
in this case I just what happens in
Nevada we hope doesn't stay in Nevada
and you don't need to have Brands you
can just call perfect strangers and say
hey
yes on three what the heck is three
three is about initiative that will let
you vote for whomever you want
regardless of party and wouldn't that be
good for you and then people would say
huh I hadn't really thought of it and
then you can say to them look right now
uh your choices are constrained you have
to pick literally you get a different
ballot based upon which party you say
you're a part of it's not fair it's not
right for voters let's make it so
everyone's on the same ballot and that
makes intuitive sense to voters they
just need to understand it and it also
you know gives significant portions of
the population a say because right now
if you're not a member of either the
parties in Most states you're not
allowed to vote in their Prime even in
New York what's it like eight months or
something that you've got to register as
a member of the party ahead of the
primary in order to vote in that primary
it's ridiculous there's just so many
people in this country they're literally
spending public money on elections that
only some people can participate in boo
yeah not right so Nevada uh you know
again that that one's below the radar
for a lot of people but the Nevada
balance initiative ranked Choice voting
and approval voting to a lesser extent
are on the ballot in different places
but this ballot initiative Nevada is the
only place where it's Statewide yeah
it's huge and for the opportunities that
Andrew was just talking about for other
ways to support all these candidates
just putting a plug-in we've got a
Weekly Newsletter that goes out
fordparty.com sign up for our email list
and you'll get all these opportunities
ways that you can plug in help out on
there all these opportunities
fordparty.com and check them out
so in total the Ford party has endorsed
27 candidates there are three Senate
candidates Evan McMullen who we
discussed Lisa murkowski who we also
touched on go Lisa beat Kelly Shabaka
who seems like a loon and Mark Kelly in
Arizona I'm heading to Arizona in a few
weeks after election day in part because
Arizona has become something of the
hotbed of whether our democracy is going
to be able to make it through this messy
messy time but then there are another 24
candidates who the Ford party endorsed
and you can check them out at
fordparty.com endorsements so how did we
settle on these 27 candidates these 24
non-senate candidates you know there's
kind of two sides to that there's the
the philosophy behind it and then the
process that we use for it and on the
philosophy in this cycle we really
wanted to send a clear message about who
we are first we're a party that does
something differently we're not afraid
to endorse candidates from the other
parties who are standing up for
democracy who are doing right things
even if we disagree with them on some of
the policies that they put forward we
think they're good people who are
fighting for this country we're happy to
get behind them so philosophically we
wanted to make sure that we were sending
that message we also wanted to make it
very very clear that the forward party
is about supporting people who are
representing local communities so that's
why we've got more endorsements on the
state and local level than we do on the
federal level those are you know the
mayor state senators State reps you know
County clerks roles like that really do
have a lot of day-to-day impact on
people's lives but they're very very
easy to to overlook especially because
you know there's 500 000 plus of these
offices across the country 70 of them
are uncontested so why even pay
attention to the election if you've only
got one choice so philosophically we
wanted to make sure that we were you
know fighting for the good candidates
out there and also showing that we're
really focused on building from a local
level so how the heck do you choose 27
out of the
so those are hundreds of thousands yeah
so that starts you know a national party
is really
50 state parties who come together and
those 50 state parties are
local people local volunteers who have
just raised their hand and said I want
to join the Ford party I want to be a
leader I want to support democracy I
want to support this new party I want to
support the values of the Ford party
wait wait just so so everyone knows
Free People thriving communities and a
vibrant democracy I want those three
things yeah if you want those three
things
come join the forward party uh or run
under the Ford party Banner we're going
to try and run a ton of uh local
candidates in 2023 in the off cycle so
uh you know if you're interested in that
go to our website we've got an intake
form and that's one of the parts of
where it started was we had plenty of
candidates over 500 candidates reach out
to say hey I want to run as a forward
Party candidate or I want an endorsement
even though I'm running as a republican
Democrat libertarian green party member
you know whatever we were happy to take
a look at anybody from there we also
went out to our state and local groups
and said hey do you have any candidates
running in the races that we should know
about we should consider because you
know they've been interacting with you
they're aligned with us they're really
putting forward values that we can all
stand behind so we ended up aggregating
all of these recommendations or
submissions into a giant list from there
we put a committee together and this is
what I think is one of the things that's
really different about what we did and
really exciting about what we did we had
a few of the members of our team from
the national you know staff come
together as this a board member who's
got a long history in independent
politics was on there as well but then
we had the state League leads vote for a
delegation to the endorsement committee
using ranked Choice voting of course and
so people put their their hands up and
said hey I would love to be on this
committee I would love to you know make
my case to the other state leads they
did that ranked Choice voting ended up
with three candidates who won that and
uh were on the committee it was a you
know just a magical magical time of
sitting down and going through all of
this
um you know we had people of very
different political backgrounds
Persuasions beliefs sit down to come up
with these endorsements and really just
talk through all of them to figure out
where we wanted to endorse candidates
who we could stand behind who is
representing our values where did it
make sense for us to get involved how we
could we send the right message about
ourselves in this cycle and it was a you
know I wouldn't say it was a heated
conversation because everybody was very
respectful but it was certainly a
conversation with a lot of disagreements
on stuff and people were able to talk
through and that's that's what's been
most most magical to me about the Ford
Party Support especially after we went
through the merger and brought brought
in the renew America serve America crew
it's just everybody here really Mission
driven principle uh reasonable can agree
to disagree can find the best conclusion
you know a bunch of forward party people
are just trying to decide where to eat
the other day and just wound up the
right choice only through
principled conversation I'm kidding but
I'm not kidding yeah um so uh so we
coalesced around these 27 candidates and
if you were endorsed by a Ford party you
get stuff right like what like what what
kind of stuff the candidates get there
there's a whole menu that was put
together on this front there's you know
the the the two parties have set up a
lot of rules on a different different
things but
um you know there's there's direct
donations that we send to certain
candidates where we're able to email us
out
um you know we can a lot of the times
we'll send an email that they have
written to their supporters out and just
say like hey this is the type of person
that we think would be a great forward
candidate so it warms my heart that we
sent cash money which I knew we did so
if you were endorsed by the forward
party you received between one and five
thousand dollars depending upon uh
campaign Finance rules nature of the
race et cetera et cetera which in a
local race I mean like that that's no
joke yeah no that's massive the amount
of money spent in some of these is in
the thousands of dollars so you know a
thousand dollars in those races can
completely
help a lot help a lot uh and then we
also sent out emails uh donor list
individual donations and so those would
be different amounts depending upon uh
the nature of of the race I personally
did multiple events for Evan as one
example that's very high end and one of
the things that I'm most excited about
because in so many of these races the
people
are so committed and so passionate to
have such a great view of what they want
to do but you're running for a small
office there's not a lot of coverage
there's not a lot of highlighting on
there we are currently in the process
this by the time this error should
already be rolling out a really just
like recording interviews recording
video with these people talking about
why uh why the Ford party means so much
to them what they want to do for their
communities and really highlighting that
through our social channels uh through
our emails so that's what I I'm most
excited about you know actually giving a
lot of these candidates who are just
fantastic people who are making great
humans of sacrifice just the chance to
tell their story to to the American
people especially to the area where they
live this could be should be a massive
Talent Development pipeline because the
fact is you're a first-time candidate
you run I've been there uh and then
let's say you lose also been there uh
and then the question is what next is
there uh Venus support is there a
community will you be able to run again
and if so will you have more resources
maybe some digital help maybe like some
uh Avid supporters who will amplify
whatever you're doing we we drew
maybe a thousand people to our Houston
event
and uh we're planning a convention for
next summer yep which is going to be
thousands maybe even you know ten
thousand plus I mean who the heck knows
uh uh and if you're running as a forward
endorsed candidate and you fall short
you can
come to that convention run again you'll
be stronger I mean this is one thing
that's meant there are a lot of messed
up things about the two-party system but
there are a lot of people that get
washed out within the two-party system
particularly if you're running in an
environment that's just unfriendly to
whatever the heck you know what I mean
like like if you're uh a democrat in a
red state or rural area and you lose I
know a lot of these people by the way
that they lose and then it's like well
like you know that's it what are you
gonna do I taught I met with one of them
who left her District uh and uh you know
was running a non-profit
um in a major blue city after losing a
congressional race in a reddish State uh
and then the reverse would be true too
where there are a lot of Independents or
Republicans and blue areas so it's like
well can't run here unless uh you know
like you're they're very very
extenuating circumstances
um so the talent development piece for
the Ford parties a huge thing I'm
excited about yeah I'm excited about
that and I'm also excited about the way
you know we don't have a fully fleshed
primary system yet that's something
we're working on and bringing in experts
and bringing in state party leads to
figure out how they want to do stuff but
with the way that the current system is
kind of set up with the the two parties
set up the way that they are so many
great people can't even put their foot
forward into the primary because they
wouldn't get support from the Democrats
or Republicans because there's a long
list of things that you have to agree
with in order to run as a Democrat or
Republican whereas the forward party
are you somebody who believes in Free
People vibrant communities thriving
democracy do you believe in these things
that also the two major parties have a
queue set up where if you were to want
to run for a race they'd say hey stand
in line yeah you've got 10 years yeah so
all of those great people out there with
great ideas that don't fit into either
of the major parties they're going to
start flocking to the forward party
because you know if you're a good person
who believes in this country believes in
our values there's room for you here and
we would rather let the forward party
voters in our primaries decide which
candidates who are putting forward real
democracy Matt Parish forbid yeah it
would be it would be terrible to let all
of our voters our supporters decide uh
which candidates are kind of terrible it
would just be terrible and letting the
candidates put forward different ideas
like I I don't think I've got the best
ideas on everything the fact that the
Republicans and Democrats think they've
already figured out the best way to run
a country when this is the country it's
not even run a country and that's the
thing that pisses me off a lot is like
that they're running on like this idea
that ideology this policy that policy
half the time they're not actually going
to do that thing it's just at this point
the two-party system is more about
maintaining the status quo and passing a
baton back and forth between each other
uh while the reality degrades uh around
the country so these 27 candidates that
we've endorsed uh they run the gamut
we've talked about some of them but
let's talk about and part of it too is
being honest some of these candidates
are not going to be successful in the
races like we were not
cherry picking to increase our batting
average uh you know like some of them
are just awesome humans who we wanted to
support because by the way also
virtually all of them are for ranked
Choice voting or non-partisanal
primaries modernizing the system which
sets them apart they might not win in 22
but 24 who knows run around 26 you know
they can run again and uh get that
experience
foreign
to talk about projections for the
midterms
um so you know this this week's just
forward forward
[Laughter]
s
we're endorsing aside from the Senate
candidates that we already discussed
yeah so I think one of the interesting
one that lines up with the Senate
candidates is we've got Clint Smith down
in Arizona Arizona capital I independent
capital I independent former Republican
did not see the current Trend especially
of the Arizona Republican party uh going
the direction that he could be a part of
so he said you know I've got to put
myself forward as somebody who's running
giving conservatives in my district an
option to vote for other than an
election denier uh you know one of the
most vocal ones out there especially
coming out of Arizona so that's a that's
a really interesting race
um unlike in Utah the Democrats are
running a candidate come on Democrats
yeah um but figure it out you know is it
a district where well you know it
because I know he's been compared to
Evan McMullen there's also a guy running
against uh Lauren bobert in Colorado
yeah and I'm fresh so that's an
interesting race because he's been
surging in the polls I think people are
getting a little sick of seeing uh the
people that they are electing and that
are supposed to represent them spending
more time on cable news networks just
saying whatever they want tweeting on
social media some of the ideologues are
genuinely vulnerable yeah you know what
I mean because people like most people
in that part of Colorado are not down
with all all of the the nuttiness I'm
going to call out one Congressional
candidate I love who's got a tough
battle Matt Diemer in Ohio running
against uh Max Miller I believe this
trumpian uh super trumpy super trumpy
figure Matt's a stud I really like mad
um and he's running a race that's
similar to Tim Ryan and where he's like
you know saying look I'm I'm running
with a d next to my name but I'm really
not like a democrat in that way uh shout
out also to Tim Ryan
um who I vastly uh prefer to his
opponent JD Vance Tim Ryan's really good
dude I met him during the presidential
but Matt Diemer is running
along a similar line line uh he's a
great guy yeah no Matt Deemer is a great
you met him at a conference somewhere
right yeah yeah
and same thing with Tim Ryan you know we
got to hang out a few times on the
presidential just really just down to
earth guy who's got a strong set of
values middle class values you know Pro
small business you know and just
fighting for what he thinks is right uh
in a state that you know is is trending
in the the Republican Direction yeah and
there's an interesting strain there are
two major uh forces that are drawing
people to forward in many ways so one is
uh the fact that the Republican party is
going dark and so you have people like
Clint Smith or even Evan McMullen who
used to be a republican uh or some of
the other folks in forward and then
there's going to be this other force
that I think is going to to be more
prominent after the midterms where in a
state like Ohio used to be a
quintessential Bellwether swing state
Ohio Obama won it uh and now it's plus
eight plus nine Republican you have Tim
Ryan who in my view is a very strong
candidate who's trying to say look I'm
not like those Democrats I'm like this
other thing
um if Tim Ryan falls short uh then I
think he's going to be in the same
position as a number of other
Democrats in reddish states where what's
the path forward for them
um and this is where I think it gets
somewhat interesting I mean the the
Democratic party is getting weaker and
weaker in rural areas there are some
folks that uh like JD scholten who are
trying to start rural Democrats uh uh
Richard Ojeda started no Democrat left
behind but the reality is the Democratic
brand is just really tarnished in a lot
of those environments I think if Tim
Ryan was running as an independent in
let's say there was no Democratic
candidate and Tim Ryan was an
independent I think he's got a better
chance to win uh and and I I think
you're going to see a number of
Democrats in those environments who are
taking a long look at forward yeah I
mean we keep seeing this after almost
every election cycle where one of the
two parties just gets shellacked or is
perceived to shellac where they go
through this post-mortem and they come
up with all these recommendations and
stuff like that then ignore all of it
and just kind of do what they were going
to do anyway yeah and I see that kind of
on the horizon on the the Democratic
side depending on how November goes
which you know based on most of the
polling seems to be the Democrats look
like they were having a little bit of uh
life over the summer now it's looking
like it's trending back in the other
direction which essentially always
happens uh in polling as you get closer
to the election day on that front but I
just don't see this has been a trend
where a larger and larger percentage of
Americans do not see either party as
representing their values may have not
seen either of the parties take a major
step to figure out why that is and to
address it and because they don't need
to yeah you know each one of them's like
yeah I can eek out a win I can eat how
to win you get that territory I get this
territory and it's hard it's hard to go
into all these communities listen to
people hear what they actually need
change yourself in order to address the
needs that people have instead of trying
to force feed your opinion on people
like oh no if only these middle class
people actually listen to the Democratic
platform then they would know that the
Democrats are really the ones
representing if your message isn't
Landing maybe you should take a look at
yourself for a little while and say what
should I change yeah I agree man the
other uh piece of it too is that
unfortunately we've degenerated to a
point when people will argue based on
messaging uh and not whether I delivered
for you I mean these testing results
just came out that showed that American
kids reading and math scores plummeted
which you could attribute largely to
covid but we've been declining for a
long time
at this point now each party has just
become more about scoring points I mean
in this case like the the people who are
aren't scoring the points are our kids
and it's uh so I I will preview a little
bit of uh next week's conversation with
Ricky or we're going to talk about the
midterms but you touched on it which is
uh it looks like the
winds are now behind the Republicans in
large part because they're top three uh
issues are inflation slash the economy
crime and immigration and those three
issues are now top of mind for more and
more Americans I talked to one guy very
very uh reliable Democratic type voter
and he said he's voting for The
Republican in his local election because
someone got shot on his block and now
he's like I'm a one-issue voter and it's
crime and I just do not believe in my
local Democratic Leadership to to do
what they need to do about it in part
because the response is that their
hearing seem to be more ideological
around crime than
um than practical
um so uh it seems that Republicans are
going to likely win the house by a
certain margin
um and then the Senate I'll dig into a
bit uh next week because that that's
going to hinge upon individual races see
how it goes over the next next few weeks
but in the meantime time sign up for
fordparty.com's email list so all right
so so
forwardparty.com check out the endorsed
candidates Evan McMullen in Utah is race
number one the ballot initiative in
Nevada is number two and then after that
find an endorsed candidate that you like
or love and then try and help them out
and if you do that some of them are
going to get across the finish line and
we're we're all going to be in better
shape for it it's I'm so pumped for this
election day we've got massive
opportunities if Evan wins if the battle
initiative in Nevada wins if a few of
the endorsed candidates uh win and
defeat some frankly really not very nice
people
I'm going to feel great about our role
in trying to move America in a better
Direction yep and regardless of whether
you live in one of the areas where we've
got an endorsed candidate vote in your
local elections it's really easy to you
know take a look at the list and just
say I don't know who any of these people
are so I'm not going to vote for anybody
take 10 seconds you won't honestly you
probably won't find most of them online
anywhere because it's most of the local
candidates don't have any opponents so
they don't bother with anything but the
ones that you do
send a message to you know the the
candidates who are running even if it's
a an uncontested election not voting for
somebody sends a message to so make sure
that you are using the most powerful
thing you have in our democracy your
your voice your vote to send a message
about what you care about yep make that
voting plan tell your friends influence
your local races uh and and let's do
everything we can for the country we've
got as of this airing we've got about a
week let's make the most of it yep thank
you Matt look at this CEO of the most
exciting new party in the country after
you've been thinking about third parties
for years and years thank you for being
here and for all the hard work you do
every day I'm always happy to especially
to highlight uh the work that our state
leads did on this front and to highlight
the candidates that we've endorsed
they're the ones who put themselves out
there yeah the forward party uh
volunteers and leads are really
exceptional humans I have loved every
single one I've met and I can't wait to
get back out and meet some more yeah
yeah and if you haven't signed up to
volunteer yet go to our website and
volunteer get involved in the the state
party a lot of them are starting to form
their executive committees start to hold
elections on all that stuff get their
bylaws going and everything and signing
up now gives you a voice in that and uh
you know we're not forcing a lot of the
decisions down on the state parties this
really is a ground up
party where the the state parties are
having a lot of voice in the decision
making process and you could you could
lend your voice to that how many states
are we currently recognized in depends
what you mean by recognize that gets
really complicated but I think that
we've got 20 states where we've taken
concrete steps towards official
recognition at different levels and then
how many we actually already achieved it
in uh we've got our Texas and
Connecticut parties which are the most
advanced and then I think we filed
paperwork in a handful of others so we
have parties in Texas and Connecticut we
do have parties in Texas and Connecticut
yes that's what I'm talking about two
down 48 to go let's go Matt to me to me
the fact that we've got State leads in
almost every state at this point is the
excitement part because I agree yeah
those are the people I'm talking about
it's um it's one thing to get official
recognition as a party that's necessary
that's the steps but to me a party is
about a bunch of people coming together
to solve problems and build something
yeah and so even if the state doesn't
recognize us as having an official party
if we've got leads if we've got
volunteers who are showing up and
talking about these things and taking
steps to making their communities yeah
that's true we got a party there yeah
yeah oh yeah it's party time it is party
time it is party time I can't wait for
the convention already but first
Election Day election day let's put some
points on the board put points on the
board get out and vote look for
opportunities to get engaged in the
races that we've been talking about
McMullen in particular yes on three in
Nevada and uh let's put some wins on the
board
foreign